dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol Jonah ifahir today
we are going to have a look at an image
creation AI called perfusion that is
completely out of this world Imagine a
text to image AI like stable diffusion
or mid-journey as a chef that can cook
any dish however sometimes we like the
dish we get but we would like to
introduce our own ingredients to it and
normally if we write a new recipe a new
text prompt we get a completely new
image a new dish however that is not
what we want what we want is the
previous dish with a new ingredient
let's have a look at an example we have
photos of our favorite teddy bear and we
would like it to create an image of it
playing with a ball in the water a
previous technique does oh I have
already looked at this image and I have
bad news it's not going to be pretty are
you ready okay here you go whoa it seems
to have fallen apart and there is no
ball anywhere to be seen now let's look
at the new technique now that's what I
call a great result I love it however
this is an emerging research field so of
course this is not the only previous
technique out there let's take this
adorable cat yes this cat is missing a
pair of headphones so let's add it with
another previous technique and nothing
look at least I see the remnants of some
crazy thoughts this earlier AI has about
headphones it sees them more as yoyos
now the new technique oh yes fantastic
and of course the new technique knows
that you can never wear enough
headphones so there we go so cool so
this new paper finally enables this kind
of personalization with something that
they call Concept what is that that is
the AI Chef's cookbook having a teddy
bear dressed like a wizard can be a
concept a sombrero can be a concept all
of these can be concept and here come
four incredible kickers one as many of
you fellow Scholars know some people
like pineapple on their pizzas and some
people like eggs on their pizzas well
here is the kicker it can fuse Concepts
together as well this is an AI that can
make that pizza happen with pineapple
and eggs at the same time but without
sacrificing the quality of the food now
that sounds like a huge challenge let's
have a look first take a teddy bear and
a teapot then ask this little AI to
dress up the teddy bear and upgrade the
teapot to have a cartoonish look and now
comes the magic a let concept number one
teddy bear fuse with Concept number two
the teapot and there we go wow and that
is not any teapot that is exactly that
teapot the same objects can be reused
with the snow paper we can not only
perform text to image but we can build
these little worlds exactly the way we
want this AI Chef feels like it can cook
anything we can keep our characters and
add our personal touch to them without
losing this character they also provided
a little taste test a user study where a
bunch of humans were asked which
examples they like best and it came out
that they not only liked this new
perfusion technique the most I have to
say I expected that at this point but
they also found something that I did not
expect at all again this the new
personalized images were found to be
almost indistinguishable in terms of
quality from the original wow and
finally number four all this is done
through rank 1 edits to the neural
network what is that that is a proper
surgical approach this means that it
introduces minimal changes to the neural
activations of the neural network to
achieve all of these changes and that is
likely why we are not losing out on the
quality of the image this is an
incredible feat Bravo Nvidia if you are
looking for inexpensive Cloud gpus for
AI Lambda now offers the best prices in
the world for GPU Cloud compute no
commitment or negotiation required just
sign up and launch an instance and hold
on to the your papers because with the
Lambda GPU Cloud you can now get on
demand h100 instances for just 199 per
hour yes 199 and they are one of the
first Cloud providers to offer publicly
available on-demand
h100xs did I mention they also offer
persistent storage so join researchers
at organizations like apple MIT and
Caltech in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lambdalabs.com papers to sign up for
one of their amazing GPU instances today
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time